next question is from Sienna you've
talked about useless college degrees
what about useless jobs or professions
all right now I know I'm going to offend
many people in our audience well as many
friends of mine who work in this
profession with what I'm about to say
and I'm not saying it to be demeaning to
the individuals who work in this
profession but I believe that this is a
superfluous profession that really
exists only from convention and that it
could be phased out if we didn't if we
decided it's over real estate agents and
let me explain
in modern 2017 in most states unless
there's a state that is really avoiding
this to try to keep real estate agents
in business you don't really need a real
estate agent to suggest houses for you
to look at you set up an online search
you go to realtor.com whatever you for
the most part in most states have full
access to everything that is on the
market that your Realtor would now the
realtor would argue I know about
listings that have not yet come on the
market yeah and I could maybe tell you
about them before they're listed or I
know the things to look for as a certain
house apartment but by and large anybody
who's remotely comfortable on the
Internet can look for the houses and
properties that they want to look at in
addition you don't actually need a
Realtor to participate in the
negotiation process some people are
uncomfortable with that but at the same
time if nobody had a realtor then it
would be much less of a big deal right
now the Realtors talk to each other the
buyer and sellers Asian you could talk
to the seller directly if you wanted to
and basically what the realtors are
doing is they're just skimming two to
five percent depending on buyers agent
sellers agent what kind of a contract
you may have two to six percent off the
top of every real estate transaction the
same realtor can sell the same house
multiple times and just every time skim
two to six percent off the top and every
and I know that I will get emails from
people saying David you don't understand
this value of the realtor that value
they coordinate the inspection they do
all these things there is no reason that
you couldn't I don't know if it was the
convention that when you have a lawyer
when you buy or sell a property it could
be the convention that the lawyers
paralegal which when it comes to real
state deals the paralegals are typically
doing a lot of the work assuming that
your what the law firm you're working
with this big enough that there are
paralegals the paralegal coordinates the
inspection or whatever the case may be I
have no problem working with Realtors my
realtor here in Massachusetts was was a
friend of mine that I went to high
school with with peace and love it's all
great but we could easily restructure it
so that you don't constantly get 2 to 6
percent being skimmed off the top by
realtors on every real estate
transaction I would have to agree and it
seems like when we discuss this topic
we're cabling the occupations that are
going to be replaced with automation or
just newer technology yeah whole minors
are kind of going out the door right now
I'm not talking about those services you
know replacing the need for people to
check you out or yak see drivers going
away because of uber drivers I also want
to mention car salespeople and really
there are studies that show that car
salespeople increase the amount of
profit for the dealership that's their
function it's not clear that car
salespeople have are responsible for it
a net increase in the total number of
cars sold yes someone might be
influenced by a sales person to buy one
car instead of another someone might be
influenced in to buy a car sooner than
they otherwise would but by-and-large
car salespeople don't put new buyers
into the market they merely either
accelerate or direct or make those
transactions more expensive there's no
reason that you need salespeople in
order to sell cars what about like a
security guard I mean a lot of these
places like let's say you go to a mall
or a bookstore yeah it doesn't seem like
the potential that you're saving by you
know preventing someone from stealing a
book or some of the merchandise there is
going to be cost effective when you
consider the fact you have to pay the
salary of the Brighton watching the
store I've thought about that a lot of
times I think they're you know kind of
useless there's a lot of stores like on
Newbury Street in Boston and some
high-end malls where you walk by and
there's a security guard standing at the
door and they're there all the time and
I think to myself this is a place that's
open normal business hours
it's very surprising to me that the
business would calculate that paying
this full-time security guard actually
is going to outweigh whatever possible
theft or burglary losses might take
place maybe that the jewelry store and
some of the products there are yeah I
figures or something but I still think
that part of it is not just a cost
benefit part of it is the idea that it
portrays a really luxurious brand
because it's sort of the marketing value
of there's a stake here at security
guard because this is really nice stuff
and people are safe when they go there I
mean you don't want people to be scared
when they're looking through books and
your little trinket although some people
are probably intimidated by the presence
of a security guard but I don't think
the calculation is how much is the
security guards salary which probably is
usually really really low I would argue
versus how much is likely to be stolen
its how much will we attract because of
the apparent prestige of needing a
security guard it's the idea that they
need a security guard that will attract
customers anyway that's just one idea
really good questions this week send in
your thoughts we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today
the last bonus show and the last show
today before the planned David Pakman
show summer vacation the show is not
going off the air please please please
don't email me next week worried that
the show has been canceled it hasn't if
the show were canceled we would have
weeks or even months talking about that
the show is not cancelled we're just
going on summer vacation and we will be
back after that summer vacation but this
isn't the end if you're a member then
you've still got today's bonus show